Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie Marvel.
Just showed a bunch of footage
from X-Men Episode one and revealed
what's going on during the season.
Which characters are coming back,
who the main villain is going to be.
So we'll break it all down.
I know there are a lot of questions
how this is going to connect
with their X-Men live action plans
and what's going on in Deadpool three.
So we'll explain that to
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
I will do full episode videos for X-Men 97
when they release them.
But basically.
The series is meant to be X-Men,
the Animated series, Season six.
They're just calling it Season
one of X-Men 97.
The reason why they use 97
is because had they not canceled X-Men,
the animated series after season
five, Season six would have aired in 1997.
recently a bunch of fans found out some
production information behind the scenes.
And it lists January 20, 24
as the premiere date.
We'll see if that sticks.
Hopefully they don't delay it again.
but in the footage that they showed off
recently
from episode one,
the X-Men are interrogating Bolivar Trask
with Jean Gray using her telepathy
to probe his mind for the truth.
They used the Trask character
during the live action
X-Men Days of Future Past Movie
played by Peter Dinklage.
His backstory was pretty similar during
that as it was the animated series in in
the comics.
he's meant to
be the scientist that originally created
the Sentinels, the send.
Those were the original antagonists
of the early X-Men,
the Animated series episodes.
Eventually, Trask learned
that master mold intended to hijack them
and use them to take over the world,
killing mutants and humans alike.
end, even though Trask didn't completely
180 on the X-Men and sympathized with them
the other mutants, he did try to help them
destroy master mold.
they were kind of ambiguous
about what happened to Master Mole.
Like ultimately they want you to think
that he's still out there
somewhere, potentially.
He was meant to be the apex evolution
of the Sentinels created by Trask
to be their control master.
Thus the name Master Mold.
But he went rogue Ultron style
during the new footage from episode one,
the new X-Men team
mostly made up of members
from the original team
with a couple of minor changes.
It's the leadership that changed
they had on an a mission
to confront the threat of new sentinels.
Now, like brand new ones.
So that's why
they're interrogating Trask again,
because he created the original ones.
they try to find out who's behind it.
And while they're on the mission,
they make a bunch of references
to their training in the danger room.
So it sounds like there's a lot of danger
room in those early episodes.
Professor
X is supposed to return eventually,
but episode one is mostly the new team
working together with Adam.
Like what is life
like with the X-Men without Professor X
they're basically picking up
where the original series left off.
And at the end of those original episodes
in the finale, Professor X almost died
after he was hit with an energy disruptor
at a mutant relations summit.
la land
or comes to take him to the R empire
where they have technology to heal them.
And that's basically how they go out
in the original finale, like the X-Men
and Magneto,
watching him leave in their absence,
Magneto tries to carry on his good name,
redeem himself in the process,
helping the X-Men standing in
for Professor X as their new leader,
Storm and Cyclops are basically meant
to be like the day to day team leaders.
Even though Magneto is technically
in charge of everything, Jean Gray starts
the season being pregnant.
I believe it's supposed to be with Kable,
a.k.a.
Nathan Summers.
It sounds like she'll give birth to him
at some point during season one.
I don't think they want to begin season
two with her still being pregnant.
They are working on season two right now
that they've already finished season one.
I don't know if they have plans for season
three yet.
They haven't talked that far ahead yet
we just saw a live action version of cable
during Deadpool two.
He's not coming back in Deadpool
three, though.
Josh Brolin, a.k.a. Thanos as well.
Like just people playing
multiple Marvel characters In the comics.
He's meant to be the son of Cyclops
and Madeline Prior,
so a little bit of a different twist.
Who was a clone of Jean Gray,
who they thought had died, created
by Mister Sinister, who was obsessed
with Cyclops and Jean Gray's bloodline.
he believed that the children
born of Cyclops and Jean Gray
would become ultra powerful Omega
level mutants that he wanted for himself.
So he was obsessed with them during
the original X-Men, the animated series.
It sounds like they're continuing that
during X-Men 97,
they'll probably be some Easter eggs
for the original comic book storyline,
but like they did a big cable storyline
during the original X-Men.
The animated series is part of Apocalypse.
The storyline like he was time
traveling to try and kill Apocalypse,
deals with a big age of apocalypse
storyline during the original series.
So don't be surprised
if we're seeing like the young cable
be born during these new episodes.
If we also see the older cable return
at some point to.
Part of the reason
why I think that storyline is taking more
center stage is because Mr.
Sinister himself is supposed to be
the main villain of season one.
At least they didn't say
what he's going to be doing
during the new episodes
beyond just messing with genetics, trying
to create superior mutants in Cyclops
and Jean Gray's on cable.
it sounds like there'll be
some larger plot that he's involved in.
Like his plans will have gotten bigger
since the original series, but
it usually just comes back around
to genetic experimentation
during the new trailer footage,
Cyclops also gets that classic
Professor X Line,
which is also a comic book line, too.
To me, my X-Men
generally, that's about all the footage
that they've revealed so far.
The new team
mostly supposed to be the same
with a few minor changes
like this is the roster here.
This new character is just a redesign
of morph.
He's back on the main team.
Remember they found out he was still alive
and then eventually he turned
good again.
a lot of people confused about this
character too.
This is just meant to be sunspot
they didn't say which episode Professor
X returns from the air empire.
But my assumption is that it'll be after
the first few episodes at least,
because they want to show
what the X-Men are doing in his absence.
Like, how is Magneto handling being leader
of the team, trying to redeem himself,
The original writers explain
what would have happened
had they continued the regular show
back in the day and they got in season six
in It sounds like the plot of X-Men
97 is basically that
like they just literally continued with
what happens to the X-Men
a couple of months
after Professor X leaves the Earth,
because it's brand new animation, too.
It's also meant to be way shinier,
like it's inspired by the animation
style of the original characters,
but done with modern technology.
So it's in 4K, HDR
and everything looks way crisper.
They've already been a couple big X-Men
animated series, Easter eggs
in the live action Marvel movies
and Disney Plus series recently.
The biggest ones being Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness when they introduced
Patrick Stewart in the A38 universe
as part of the Illuminati, his character
design was meant to look exactly
like Professor X from the animated series.
they even played the song
from the animated series.
this is Sam Raimi and the writer
talking about
making him a version
from the animated series
Generally, all the X-Men characters
in the A3 universe,
not just the one that you see
here, are meant to be based on X-Men,
the animated series
versions of the characters
Deadpool three is also supposed
to revisit the universe,
and it sounds like that's
how they're going to explain
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine, wearing
the comic book Accurate Yellow Suit.
they'll just say
that he's also based on the version
from X-Men, the Animated series.
during the Ms..
Marvel series, you may have heard
when they were revealing that she was also
a mutant, they also played the X-Men,
the animated series
theme music.
so Kevin Fire
clearly wants people thinking of X-Men
in the original series.
For those of you asking
whether or not it's
going to be canon to the MCU, though,
generally you're supposed to look at it
the way we look at what if being canon
to the MCU, like technically it is canon,
but it's all happening
in different universes.
So X-Men,
the animated series is canon, but
it is happening in an alternate universe.
the A38 universe isn't meant
to literally be the universe from X-Men.
The animated series
is just meant to be very, very similar.
Expect more Easter eggs from the animated
series during Deadpool three, though
for those of you asking what's happening
with the new X-Men live action movie,
the Kevin Feige
said that they were also developing
the supposedly not going to be doing that
till sometime, probably
after Secret Wars comes out Bill,
introduce more X-Men characters.
But right now the plan is that Kevin
Foggy wants to have a big swan song
going out for all the original X-Men
actors like the Fox Marvel actors,
and that's happening in Deadpool three.
Like it's meant to be a big homage
going out for those characters.
And in Secret Wars,
because of all the multiverse.
they get their big swan song
in those Avengers movies.
Then Kevin, he starts introducing
new versions of the MCU, X-Men.
those will probably use secret wars
to retune things like some soft reboot
to explain how mutants start
popping up all over the place
on the main 616 MCU Earth.
but that's meant to be the main reason
why we're seeing the new Fantastic
Four movie before the new X-Men movie,
just because we have Deadpool
three coming in.
Kevin Feige,
he wants to have all these images
to the classic versions
of the X-Men actors.
once they're done with Secret
Wars, though, they're like,
they're going to kill off
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
He'll always be Wolverine
in a certain part of the multiverse,
but there will eventually be
a new recast version of Wolverine.
It's just going to be a while
before we actually see that character
got some plans to pay off,
some long running deleted scenes
and Easter eggs
with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
First, it's going to take a few years
to get that done.
we probably won't get that full X-Men
trailer till later this year
for the new series, hoping
it doesn't get delayed again.
What if season two is like
the other animated series
that's basically ready to go
and has been delayed?
It's been sitting on a shelf
for a while now.
They'll release that after X-Men
97, Season one.
Let me know if you have
any other questions about the series
and I'll do more videos
as they release more footage
and we get more Easter eggs
during the Deadpool
three movie, we'll start
getting trailers and more Easter eggs
from that in the next year or so.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Asoka episodes will start really soon.
Loki Season two episodes, right?
That of course
will do videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts on my channel.
So you don't miss any of that.
click here for that
brand new Asoka Mannequin Skywalker video
and click here for that brand new Loki
Season 2 trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!